okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel and
welcome to not the pregame um today
we're going to do conversations with a
maybe feminist
um before i start guys do not forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
um
and we actually don't have a sponsor
today so
none of that um why don't you guys
introduce yourself we have two special
guests here
one special guest
sara garvey um you guys have seen me a
few times on pearl's channel um if you
haven't followed already you better
follow my youtube and my tik tok
and
my
instagram s-a-r-a-g-a-r-v-e-y
yeah that's about it
all right what's up y'all it's jessica
y'all seen me a few times most of y'all
hate me but it's all right
get used to me baby
i'm not going no [ __ ] where
um seriously though what's up y'all it's
jessica you know you already know follow
me on tick tock jessica delex
c-h-e-s-k-a-d-e-l-i-c
okay so um jessica you went a little
viral oh i did not bother to look at
what was going on to be honest i didn't
see [ __ ] about it
um so i brought you guys on because you
guys butt heads a little bit last time
yeah
like
what
um
because jessica has an aggressive
personality
you feel attacked that's not my problem
no it's not about being me being
attacked like i said do you have an
aggre you you yourself says you have an
aggressive personality so i absolutely
did right okay so that's why you know i
decide to rescind that statement because
at the end of the day i don't think i'm
aggressive i think i'm just very
passionate
and realistically my voice is not super
girly like i'm not like
no that's that's just not me so i know
realistically i'm going to come off a
little bit more aggressive i'm going to
come off sounding like a [ __ ] man
that's fine yeah i could live with that
but i don't i genuinely don't think that
i'm aggressive i just think that i have
a very passionate personality so when i
really feel something when i feel
strongly about something i'm going to
make it known
but you did try to mock me a few times
also though
and i feel no shame
see that and that's the br and i think
that's
me plenty of times through the show
please don't start to adopt innocence
i did a monkey mans was hollering about
me the whole show
no attention to anybody else but me i
did it
i didn't mock you but yeah that's
probably why people were like
you know like
what's wrong with this girl she's just
aggressive
there's nothing
wrong with it though
nothing wrong with you being aggressive
nothing wrong with me being passionate
no well well that's the word you're
using today but before you said
aggressive yeah i think that's just
because i didn't know how to properly
word it at the time however now i can
reflect and say nah i wasn't being
aggressive i was just being passionate
so do you still think that i'm
intimidated by you
because that's what you said
that's what you said i don't really care
if you're intimidated or not like i was
just playing with you right
but i mean if you do feel that way since
it was on your mind that much maybe you
might have no because because when it
went viral i'm thinking about it i even
forgot i said that i'm not gonna lie to
you yeah but that's what people were
saying a lot in the comments because you
were like oh because you know because
you're intimidated by me and i'm gonna
say no i'm definitely not intimidated by
you
but do you feel like like it's like you
felt like people are intimidated by you
um it's not that i feel that way it's
that a lot of people have said so
a lot of people have approached me like
like people who like may not have been
my friend yet you know like if i first
meet them they'll be like i was honestly
very intimidated by you i think like
your demeanor comes off like very strong
you know that doesn't necessarily mean
it's a bad thing it's not like i give
like negative aura or something like
that i'm not walking around like angry
[ __ ] face all the time but i know that
my energy is a little bit different for
most people but then people get to know
me and they're like oh my god you're so
much nicer than i thought like you're so
sweet this and that and i'm like yeah i
mean i don't have to be super nice to
everybody right away you know i don't
know you
we gotta like form a friendship here
before i start you know treating you
like one of my close friends so
yeah
i also think it like
i think there's a difference between
like maybe the us and the uk
when it comes to like the way people
interact
yes we're louder yeah you guys are like
louder and more like we're more enthus
enthusiastic though like like
me and gabby have been in situations
where like telling a story to like like
british people right and we just get so
into it we'll be like yeah
yeah and like the british people in the
room will be like what is wrong with
these girls there were a couple times
where like
you know people would be like get to the
point of the story and i'm like no but
you have to hear this like you have to
know what i'm about to talk about you
have to know the whole thing you have to
know the whole story the whole story i
have to be like mind you on this day at
this time this happened like you know
like i realize people are very like
short straight and to the point but i
feel like that kind of
loses the
fun interaction behind like social
interaction you know like that kind of
loses its
genuineness behind it like i feel like
we don't have to rush conversation we
can have fun and like talk about things
in detail because that
that's what makes it fun like i'm a
storyteller like i sure as hell i'm a
storyteller so if you ask me a question
i probably will give you a story behind
it
so so question um i'm not sure because
you kind of you say a lot of things that
are are very much like feminists like
feminists say them but at the same time
you're not sure if you identify as a
feminist right yeah the reason why i
have difficulty
pegging myself as a feminist is
i feel like it
i think society's viewpoint of feminism
is extreme okay you know because
oftentimes when we see feminists it's
the more extreme side of it right like
we could say the same thing for certain
religions races whatever it may be so in
this case like the social construct of
feminism and equality or equity
like people tend to look at it in a
negative way and i'm very much an equal
rights equal less person yeah you know
like
if i see a woman is [ __ ] up i will
call it out like it is like i i fully
believe in that because i feel like a
lot of people do let women get away with
bs that doesn't need to be happening
okay so i think that's the reason why i
don't really come off as a feminist per
se i think i just really believe in
what kind of bs do you think that women
get away with
sometimes abusing men i feel like that's
like the most basic thing that i could
come up with now
um
because like i said briefly in the last
uh time that i was here like my mom was
abusing my dad straight up but my dad
couldn't really do much about it you
know because like
everyone's thinking like oh this poor
woman
she must be getting abused by her man so
she has to fight back or something like
nah it's not it's really not like that
it's really my mom being abusive and
people would be very quick to take a
woman's side in a case where she very
well might be wrong like the johnny depp
case right now yeah that is a freaking
mess like we need to hold this woman
accountable she is a menace to society
so what like what points do you agree
with feminism on
like what where do you think um like
what are we missing in 2020 don't you
think that because feminism like came in
waves didn't it she had first wave
second wave third wave feminism so
i think it's kind of difficult to answer
that because i need like a an example
right so that i can say like yeah i
agree or no i don't and this is why
because like first wave feminism i agree
with okay personally
women want equality you want equal pay
you know um you want to be treated just
as a man's treated i'm down with that i
think the the waves after that it got
progressively and progressively worse in
my personal point of view like it for me
feminism became
not so much equality but now about
revenge
and
i said on my show the other day right
that
feminism this newer form of feminism has
given women the power
to be
just like the most heinous man or the
most heinous men in history
right you know the abusers the sexual
abusers the people that used to talk to
people derogatory but giving them the
the get out of not having accountability
for doing it
that's what i believe feminism today has
done i believe it's you can say you know
what [ __ ] men they're this they're trash
and there's no accountability on your
side but see i feel like that's not true
feminism then i think that's just being
a misandrist
at the end of the day like
that's something that's not spoken about
enough though misandry is not spoken
about enough oh i agree i think that's
like 90 of feminists today if i'm being
honest like
when when i talk to most feminists they
have a slight disdain for men
like even if i say oh we need men in
society like we argue
well i believe in that because we need a
balance at the end of the day we we're
gonna need both men and women at the end
of the day if we're gonna uh function
properly because there's some things
that men can do and some things that
women can do that the other
gender of sex cannot provide you need
men to build stuff
if we're honest yeah no i mean they
didn't mean like a shelf
no like they're like what do you mean
like
like like are we talking about like
building the shelf from ikea like no
like the mic that you're using right now
this stuff yeah like they run the
infrastructure of society like most if
if men disappeared today society would
collapse if women disappeared it
wouldn't
outside of reproductive reasons yeah i
can agree with that
but i always bring it back to the
foundation of what like these countries
and infrastructure has been built on
right so like which is when we look at
like stem majors for example a lot of
engineering all that kind of stuff uh
it's not woman dominated whatsoever you
know like
i don't know what the statistics are
exactly but i i can guarantee you it's
it's definitely going to be less than 30
of women in stem or something it's
changed a lot throughout the last like
10 to 15 years that's a guarantee but
before then it was mostly men in these
types of um positions and majors and all
that because
women weren't really given an interest
into it they weren't really given a
like a pathway but now that they are
it's enjoyable yeah and it's great that
we're in it now but not everybody is no
but now they are they're not choosing
them
they're not choosing women generally
aren't choosing the stem fields
i feel like i know a lot of women in
stem but i can only speak from
statistically they're not choosing it
yeah it's just like the numbers don't
back that up so because if you if they
um they did a study where they took the
countries that have the most choice when
it comes to like jobs you know what i'm
saying like so you take like
more you know like middle eastern
countries where women have less choice
and you take more egalitarian countries
where women have more choice and the
more choice that women have like the the
more they choose jobs that have to do
with people and not things
because women like we value
relationships yeah so you'll see more
women going into like medicine yeah like
midwifery and what like middle should be
a midwife so yeah social care and and
realistically though that's because
that's our strength you know we have a
nurturing kind of nature to us that men
often times cannot provide at the end of
the day yeah so like i see nothing wrong
with women not stepping into stem more
than before
like it's okay
i i do agree with you in that sense that
like hey man so then if if you believe
in like equal or if feminists believe in
like equal
um
opportunities right
you don't even equal opportunity doesn't
um equal
equal outcome
we talked about this briefly
i agreed
i agreed with that fully i'm the type of
person where it's like if you can't step
up to the plate and deliver
it's not for you point-blank period like
and if you really want to continue
whatever field you're going into by all
means do so but you're gonna have to
work twice as hard you know and
especially if you're a woman you know
and in a male dominated situation you
might be looked at a little bit more
crazy
so
so what do you think like feminists are
really fighting for in 2022 because i
just like genuinely bottom of my heart i
feel like as a woman i'm not oppressed
at all i don't think there's anything
stopping i'm in a very male dominated
sector of youtube and i think being a
woman's an advantage not a disadvantage
your subscribership keeps going up and
up and up yeah like i i honestly i've
always been in like male dominated
fields fields i worked in sales and i my
mom was also in a male dominated field
and we've always said no it's an
advantage
um because you stand out more okay um so
i just
i can't think of anything like any
rights that i don't have in 2022. well
if we look at what's going on now
especially in like a couple of states
like south and west word at least in the
u.s
um there's a lot of
bodily autonomy issues that i think like
that so abortion yeah things like that
exactly but then there's also like cases
where gynecologists male gynecologists
specifically will impregnate women with
their own sperm like crazy things like
that like i think how often does that
happen though it doesn't matter how
often it happens the problem is that it
happens at all
and it happens enough for us to talk
about it and we know about it
i don't know what i'm saying no but i
don't i don't advocate for it i don't
advocate for it
okay
okay finish your sentence yeah go around
[ __ ]
finish your so so in general i think the
fight for feminism now
mostly revolves around sexual assault
um or any type of domestic violence and
bodily autonomy i think that's what
we're
mainly pushing for at least okay and
what were you going to say sorry yeah
because like i i obviously i don't
advocate for you know gynecologists and
pregnant impregnating their patients
yeah but um
listen anomalies happen
that's an uh i would guess that's an
anomaly um when it comes to
bodily autonomy or abortion i personally
have very strong views on abortion i
don't believe in abortion i don't
believe women should be able to kill
children in their womb just because they
made a mistake sexually i don't like um
i feel like if you make that mistake
that's your mistake that's your burden
to handle you know i don't believe that
you should be using
abortion as contraception because prior
to getting pregnant you have
multiple ways as to not get pregnant you
know there's multiple ways not to get
pregnant and if you and if you have
chosen by for whatever reason not to do
that then that baby's yours and not only
yours it's also the guy that you were
having sex with
i fully understand and i agree with you
to a certain extent
the issue here is that
i think a majority of the time that
abortion does happen it's not just
because somebody was willy-nilly just
being sexually active and did a whoopsie
daisy
yes like it actually is i think it is it
actually is i actually only only
okay so i'll give statistics so about
which country are we talking about um
the uk the us and the uk one percent
about one to two percent of abortions
are because someone was either graped or
molested right the other
um there's a i think maybe
five percent because the contraception
didn't work
okay the rest of them is because people
wanted to have sex
and and they made them know where you
got these statistics from i'll get them
for you because i did it on my show okay
i pull out your phone
because no because jessica like honestly
every girl i know that's had an abortion
they were irresponsible like they
weren't even on birth control or pulling
out so in that case i understand no in
that case i fully understand because
like my dad raised me to believe the
same thing like he was like listen at
the end of the day if you feel like
you're grown enough to get sexually
active you better put on your big girl
panties and know what might come out of
it right so i fully agree with that but
in a case where somebody is assaulted or
incest or anything like that
so so would you if there was a law that
said it was only in the case of assault
or great that abortion is allowed would
you agree with that then
like because i think it's hard it's hard
to
like say whether or not i would agree
with it
i feel like to a certain extent i would
but then it's still
controlling women's bodies and what
choices they get to make that's the
other problem that i'm struggling with
it's like this is where i struggle with
figuring out whether i'm a feminist or
not yeah because it's like yes i fully
believe in bodily autonomy i believe
that we should be able to make the
decisions
that we want to with our bodies
however
there a line can be drawn you know
especially when it comes to abortion
like so from the sorry to cut you from
the good marker institute it says
thirteen percent
they do like white papers all the time
can you pronounce this this is a german
organization
it says that german organization well
german he says it's in the u.s
from the u.s right it says 13 so it's 13
was because of the pill okay so 13 of
abortions they said the women were
saying i was on the pill it didn't work
so 13 so if we got 13 because of pill
and then we've got
one percent because of grape
that that's only what let's say 15 yeah
so let's say the majority 85 of
abortions are because of
bad sexual practice
yeah but then that then we'd have to
bring it back another step we'd have to
think about the sexual education
uh system then because it's like why are
people having children so willy-nilly
then right why are they so comfortable
with
did you know what's interesting we have
more access to contraception yep and
more access to sexual education
and
more out of wedlock pregnancies
so what does that say about a society so
so then
where is the evidence that sex ed
and contraception has been helpful
like it seems like if anything it's had
the opposite effect here's the thing
just because we have more access to it
doesn't mean that it is successful right
right so a lot of like we have to think
about like again i can only speak on the
us terms because i don't i don't know
like the school system anywhere else but
when you look at
the school curriculum state by state
they're all wildly different like if you
look at texas versus new jersey
we're learning two completely different
things prioritizing different things at
least there are a lot of schools out
there
that bark at students to practice
abstinence rather than safe sex right
and we already know how young teens
minds go they're going to be like oh but
i really want to do it yeah why can't i
do it i went to one of those schools
yeah but to be honest there were no
pregnancies in my school yeah i mean and
so like i i just that's why i don't
really buy into like the sex ed thing
because if that was true like we would
be running crazy with with pregnant kids
because all we had every year was an
abstinence speaker and honestly like
like it helped like i was a virgin until
i was like 1920 and that was that was
later than most like yeah you know what
i mean but like i think that really also
depends on the culture of like where
you're from right like if you're from a
more conservative area i think naturally
it might be more like that but i'm from
a more liberal area so
my school personally didn't have like
teen pregnancies like at all
but i know a couple of neighboring
schools that did have issues with that
yeah and it's like
their sex ed
you know classes weren't necessarily the
best on top of the fact that most of
them were from lower income uh areas so
i'm just curious like what would good
sex ad look like to you so like what
would if you're in a perfect like chess
gets to make the laws
like like what what really putting me on
the spot today
i'm just curious like what would that
look like for you um i would want um
students to know every single available
option that they have because i don't
think people realize how many options
they have for contraception okay right
what age would you teach it
well i started learning sex ed in fifth
grade i think that's i don't know what
that is what age is that oh god that's
about
10 10 or 11 years old that's a little
young for i mean you say that now but
they're giving you you could get your
period as young as nine years old so you
kind of have to do they're giving talks
in stores schools now about
transgenderism at like eight so
i don't know
um okay so you would put so in 10 11
yeah i'd probably go for about that age
range because that is exactly when our
bodies start changing rapidly so and you
would tell them like okay if you had
like this is what sex is from the school
yeah and you would from the school say
these contraceptions this is what you
can use yeah like this is what happens
out of sex i think the the problem
is that oftentimes school really just
like looks at sex from a very scientific
perspective and they expect the students
to learn
the more emotional aspect from their
parents but we can't really trust
so i'm just curious like so you bring in
10 11 year olds and you would say this
is how to have like this is not how to
this is what sex is but in other words
like later on
yeah but like how to have sex in a way
i mean yeah but like the thing is i had
that conversation with my son the other
day
and he's nine okay i never told i just
asked him as a matter of fact has he
heard of what sex is
and he's like yeah it's when people kiss
and i was like okay exactly why the
education is necessary okay it's where
people kiss yeah
do you know what i'm saying so the thing
is that at this age
children unfortunately are being exposed
yeah more so to what sex is or sexual
type even sexual type language
is being used within schools nowadays
you know i don't think it's just
nowadays i think it's even from when we
were young and even some of our parents
generation you look at cartoons and tv
shows and all that always see these like
subliminal messages like oh my god all
the time like they were always dirty
powerpuff girls can we talk about the
mayor can we talk about the mayor
have you not seen that there's a there's
a youtube clip about um the cartoons
yeah they made a cartoon clip of all the
cartoons when you were young that had
sexual innuendo they've put them all
together and watching it you're like
this is what i was watching this is some
crazy like i will never forget spongebob
pulling out some soap and telling gary
like don't drop them because like they
were acting like pirates and he's like
look doubloons and yeah and it's like
not only are we bringing in uh a sexual
assault joke but also
jail what's this but what's disney doing
now with the cartoons right there's a
whole thing about disney bringing in the
whole trance thing with the cartoons and
that whole thing so yeah i just think i
don't know i think children are being
exposed to um but i mean what's that
what's wrong with that though i'm trying
to understand i think you should protect
kids innocence honestly like because one
people but what's not innocent about
about being transgender
no i'm looking at it oh you're talking
about truth because because
transgenderism is like it's an anomaly
right and it's like
children that much of an anomaly if we
have to talk about it is my point though
yeah but children all right so but
children shouldn't be taught about in my
personal point of view should we talk
about shouldn't it be taught about sex
at a young age anyway especially not a
sexual orientation that in my personal
point of view is about um
confusion
more so than sexual orientation so it's
like are you trying to show children
that
this sexual orientation is quote unquote
normal
where if we look at it it isn't
it's first of all it's an anomaly
second of all they talk about it's it
can be a but why not it can be
it can be looked at as a as a
psychological or physiological because
they say gender dysphoria
explaining to a nine-year-old child what
gender dysphoria is they don't know what
gender is for yourself so it you could
keep it simplistic is my point you have
to keep it kid-friendly but the thing is
transgenderism isn't simplistic
you're making it seem like it's far more
complicated than it is you can just say
here is someone who was born a boy they
don't feel comfortable being a boy they
don't feel like they're right in their
body and in their mind they feel more
comfortable with playing with the girls
they he they like playing with the dolls
and the makeup and whatever it may be
that
what you know
that's
exposing them that's exposing them to
like mental issues at such a young age
yeah so you think being trans is a
mental issue
of course it is it's not a phys it's not
a biological uh you don't have to say of
course yeah take it down a notch no but
it's no but it's true it's not it's not
a biological one
it's a mental one right
if you think you're something that
you're actually not that's in your head
just like you think you're a ten out of
ten what
i never said you think you're 11 out of
10 which is in your head so what i'm
trying to say is if you're if you're
talking about
something that isn't if we can look in
your body and we can see you have two
testicles and the penis
we know what you are right if you think
you are other than what you actually are
that's something going on in your head
right because couldn't i identify as a
teenager
if i wanted to trans age they call it
no i'm serious
what if i said i feel i feel 17. yeah i
am 17. well that would genuinely be
something that you would have to work
with and being someone who studies psych
yeah that would more than likely be a
trauma response
because
people who struggle
with their age at least right
um who still feel like they're stuck in
their teen years or even childhood years
usually experience some sort of terrible
trauma at that age in their life and
that's where they feel emotionally and
physically stunted yeah so that's why
like maybe later on they still act a
certain way for years but it's
interesting because you're kind of
saying like that's a that's like a
mental disorder yeah no i can i can say
that with peace yeah
but but trans wouldn't be so trans women
i can't see it that way because i'm
someone who's part of the lgbt community
yeah and i see how these people struggle
and
like you know like people tend to make
the argument that that's an emotional
response it's not a logical one
do you want to answer or not yeah but
it's not quite an emotional response yes
it's a yes or no question
it's a yes or no question a logical one
it's a yes or no question
let's talk about the facts not the
feelings please
i think guys get along
let's talk about the facts of the
feelings it's like
regardless these things were removed
from the dsm-5 yeah
being transgender gender dysphoria is
still in there i believe and they're
working on the dsm-6 i believe if not
it's already out but um
it's difficult to pinpoint that as a
mental illness
only because this is a whole
this is something that someone's willing
to change their entire life for i
changed my entire life to be seventeen
i mean [ __ ] you could try you could try
hang on rachel doesn't change her entire
life to be black oh my gosh do you know
who that is yeah right she was head of
the naacp
and she was a white woman yeah so just
because she identifies or thought of
herself as black doesn't mean that she
is but that doesn't make these people
any less human i think that's what i'm
trying to do we're not no but we're not
talking as i'm saying you're talking
from an emotional standpoint i've never
said trans people or whoever you are are
less human they are human beings they
deserve their rights as a human human
being
but it doesn't mean that's what they're
saying respect their identity is the
issue
so if a trans person would you mean
respect their identity if somebody were
to come to you right now they were trans
they once were she
and became he
and you knew this would you refer to
them as
what they are comfortable with or what
they were originally born as i would
refer to them as who they are which is a
man or a woman biologically because what
you're asking me to do essentially so
then that's just disrespectful no it's
not just in disregard
i'll tell you what's disrespectful
what's disrespectful for me is to ask me
to buy into your delusion
that's what i think is disrespectful if
i come up to you and say listen i know
i'm a black man but please call me uh
mei ling because i'm now a chinese woman
you're going to be like
all right you're a chinese i'm a chinese
woman really and you've met me and you
know me prior to me identifying as a
chinese woman you're now going to call
me meiling i'm now asking you
to
do to buy into my delusion if i feel
like this that's
100 cool but i shouldn't ask you
to buy into what i think of myself
because like i said you think of
yourself as a 11 out of 10.
right if you went around asking people
to call you an 11 out of 10 and that's
just plain arrogant and egotistical
because you're awesome i wouldn't do
that though right but
yeah but trans people all i ask is basic
respect
people who do they ask people to call
them the thing that they know that they
actually aren't
or the way they see themselves genuinely
not that hard to just refer to them as
she her or he him as they ask and by the
name that they choose to go by it's
genuinely not that hard my name is
francesca right but i go by chesca that
is my preferred name all i have to do is
tell you hey this is what i prefer to be
called feel free to call me this right
and it would be up to you to call me
cheska i would like i said i would
prefer it if you call me francesca i'm
not going to respond because
realistically i i don't like that name
as much as cheska
it's that song
it's a it's a respect thing no it's not
shooting in your name
yeah it's not the same as asking me to
call you by a totally different gender
okay so there's no part of you that is
that gender if they preferred a
different name even you wouldn't go with
that
if they preferred it
like i said you're asked i'm not about
they went with a different name i am not
buying anything into someone's dilution
yes or no say again it's really not that
hard of a question apparently they asked
me to cool if they asked me to call them
a name if i came to you and i said i
prefer the name richard even though i
clearly am not biologically male i'll be
like what what what are your parents
okay what are your parents you're not my
parents so you wouldn't have a right to
call me whatever it is you wouldn't have
the right to ask me to call you wouldn't
have the right to call me by whatever my
parents call me because my parents are
different from you you're just a 40 year
old man okay you're just a stranger that
i see on the topic you don't touch me
now
you're just a stranger that i see on a
podcast so chess go like okay
so i i honestly if i if i knew you know
we call that we call that sign language
over here
if i knew someone that was trans i would
probably like i probably would call them
by their name like just because they
asked me to but but the issue i get is
when we start letting people live in
delusion there's consequences and i
really do on some level think that it's
delusional because you're saying you're
something you're not
and and the problem is now we have leah
thomas coming in who's that leah thomas
the swimmer the swimmer okay and
swimming in the women's division
and taking away opportunities from women
like real biological women because in my
opinion we we started by letting them
live in delusion
okay and it slowly got to the point that
now actual real women are losing
opportunities in athletics right okay
right that's what happens when you live
that's what that's what happens when you
say oh but they feel a certain way so we
have to respect it
genuinely it has real world as much as i
would love to um
you know give a viewpoint on that i
can't okay because
one i'm not trans i feel like i can't
speak on it until i speak to other trans
people who are athletes as well as
cisgender people who are athletes and
see how they feel about it and two i'm
still
curating my research on that because
i'll be honest
throughout high school i felt that way
yeah i was like why the hell are trans
people ending up in
divisions that i feel like they're not
supposed to be i realized that so that
happened at your school
no
i realized that um
it was me
denying their identity in a sense right
um i know that realistically no matter
what this person was born opposite of
what they are but i do not want to i uh
deny
how they feel
and what they've experienced since more
than likely such a young age about what
they identify as
but at the same time like i i have to
look at the science behind this right
like because i've seen a lot of trans
people come out and say like listen my
my body has changed completely
specifically with women at least trans
women
um they're like
i don't understand why people get so
upset about trans women entering women's
divisions because estrogen really does
break down our like muscle mass and like
our strength that we had as men
previously bone density though
no
i'm sure but that's what i'm saying
that's why i'm saying like i have to do
more research on it first before i can
really curate an idea on it um but i'm
kind of like cheatering with it because
i could understand like i used to feel
that way genuinely like i was like yo
i'm a girl and i i feel like i'm
fighting for my [ __ ] life and it's
already hard enough as a black girl at
that right like
we we have to deal with [ __ ] from
both racism and sexism yeah well i just
think it's like disrespectful to like to
honestly to when real women like women
that were born that way because we go
through [ __ ] they'll never go through
they will never go for a smear test yeah
but here there's nothing to understand
like like what what do we deem a real
woman though
like i'm just curious what's a real
woman a woman that was born biologically
i'm with uh what is it actually a woman
xy xx sorry xxx chromosome and a wound
and i i know they're gonna like bring
out exceptions to them
intersex people
the few girls that have fertility issues
but that's very different than
surgically changing a dick into a vagina
okay no i i hear you i hear you
um
i think again like because i'm part of
the community yeah i have more insight
on how they feel about it yeah and i can
go off of that better as opposed to the
like i said this isn't how you feel not
when i'm done speaking listen why are
you talking about feelings we're talking
about facts
bro you're gonna have to stop him before
i do what are you going to do
listen
what are you what are you trying to do
nothing i'm just asking the question so
like so like it's a it's a we're all
talking right yeah but that's what i'm
saying we've been able to interact fine
yeah and you know if we cut each other
off we're like all right like gucci like
oh wait my bad like whatever i just
don't know right here just keep popping
like i just don't like anything
like you just don't like being cut off
by a man that's what it is like it is so
irritating you don't like being caught
up by a man no because you keep on
saying like oh factual we're feelings
facts over feelings like no like at
least when pearl is interrupting me
she's saying like oh wait but
like this is this is what i see this is
what i know you're just saying no facts
over feelings what if what if he puts
butt facts over you
feelings yeah
he could get [ __ ] slapped i just like
like do you know what i'm saying like
really like and i think what he's trying
to say is like their feelings about it
don't really matter
it's all about life but if we function
if we functioned off of only logic and
reality we would be a heartless society
genuinely i believe that
i don't know i think i think carlos
second place
the girl that got second to leah thomas
would be cool right now okay so okay
balance is needed okay times have we
looked at like politicians for example
just going based off of their emotions
sheer emotions yeah like
and not even in a not even close to
logical sense you can find a balance
between emotion and logic yeah you can
find a common ground i think you
understand
ah
anyway
we can find a balance between emotion
and logic i do believe that there are
times where we have too much logic and
too much emotion right what'd you say
ah what japanese would you think that
was too much emotion or too much logic i
think it was me telling you to shut the
[ __ ] up because you don't know how to
sometimes
but anyway
i said what i said all right no i hate
you i had you i had you to go hand in
hand in times like this when there's too
much emotion involved
people can genuinely get hurt
and when it comes to logic i feel like
logic most of the time you can't go
wrong but sometimes when we're too
logical it can really disregard a group
of people or whatever it may be you know
yeah but that's but that's one of the
problems i'm talking about we're not
talking about disregarding people
but that's not one
but
the fact that people um
actually think that speaking things that
make sense is disregarding people is
where we have a problem in the society
because if somebody is speaking to make
sense and you take it as oh you're
disregarding me no like i said i think
these people trans people deserve their
human rights i don't think of them as
less as a human being i'm saying when it
comes to things like you coming into ah
and when it comes don't speak when it
comes to you um going into a sports
arena that is not actually meant for you
and it's meant for biological women then
we see real world consequences to um
your feelings and people catering to
people's feelings that's what i'm saying
but
again i said that i cannot curate an
opinion on that until i do more research
i will not open my mouth on something
that i don't know
[ __ ] about at the end of the day you
know like that that would just be dumb
so but okay so for you the main thing
that you agree with feminism on like the
main rights that women need to see today
is abortion
bodily autonomy
because it's not always just you know
it's not it's not just abortion like in
some states or at least some counties
it's legal for
a police officer to assault an inmate
that's
while they're in custody right like so
let's say i were to be um arrested
and a cop could take me to whatever
little jail cell at whatever little
uh you know place for custody
he could sexually assault me legally
are you sure yes
okay i i promise you can do some
research on it i haven't seen
hang on you can legally sexually assault
somebody
yes a cop specifically like what are you
talking what are we classing a sexual
assault now that's what i'm trying to
understand so what what is this sexual
assault that this man can do legally
what is it that you can do great
legally yes technically he can yeah in
some states it's like an outdated law
but it's still in place and it does
happen to people
i mean i'd love to see the research on
that i'm not gonna i'd love to see the
research on that do you do you have it
i'm just curious
i'll see if i can find it because i i've
just never that sounds like kind of wild
to me can i can i before we get before
we continue
just point out um chesca's female
privilege i said when she threatened to
slap me
do you think that do you think that it
would have been received well if i
threatened to slap her
yeah she's like because i would have
been laughing one more [ __ ]
person
if it would have been received the same
way i'm just asking that's it
right okay
just glad we're just just establishing
that it wouldn't
um
okay you don't believe in abortion sarah
um no i i think abortions are quote
unquote okay in
in in instances of grape and molestation
because if sex is non-conceptual
sorry if sex is con is consensual
and you had non-consensual sex and a
baby is a result of that
that actual act was non-consensual so i
get i understand why you'd want to get
rid of the child because the sex was
non-consensual so the child would be
non-consensual
if you have consensual sex
and the child is a result then you've
consented to having a child i'm just big
into like taking ownership like i just
feel like deal with the consequences
that you chose right like
like you you pay and i said i i'm a
pearl i made a um i done a live on
abortion right and i spoke about
specifically abortion within the black
community
sometimes black women have brought their
babies three times higher than other
communities well isn't it but the reason
behind that is because planned
parenthood
more particularly was created for
it was the eugenics movement exactly
yeah it was like that's exactly it
that's like the main issue however
that's changed
and more white women apparently are
getting abortions
okay you could say no no because i've
done the research on it anyway i'm gonna
go use the restroom okay
wait wait what did you say
um
even even to this day
um
abortion happens
per capita
more high within the black community
yeah right amongst and even though you
know even in america
however many percentage of uh however
many percent of america is actually
white women
black women over represent
abortion per capita
they over represent it so it's like the
prison system in america black men are
over represented in the prison system
even though the majority of people in
prison are white because america is a
predominantly white country
but black men are overrepresented given
given the percentage of black people
within the country so if you're only
like 13
of black people in the country why do
you make up like 45
of the prison system does that make
sense so within when it comes to
abortion within the black community
black women um
uh
have a certain higher percentage of
abortions per capita than other women
and it's to me like it's something that
i feel quite strongly about and you know
it's something that obviously women
don't want to really hear about do you
know what i mean because they get they
accept you but you know they they get in
their feelings about it but i'm just
like well why and
you can't my whole thing is you can't
scream quote unquote black lives matter
right if black lives don't matter before
they even get a chance to have a life in
the womb that's a um i've heard i'm not
i'm not positive this is correct but
i've heard the black population in the
us would be double today if it wasn't
for abortion probably yeah
since 1973 when abortion became um
became legal in america
more black babies have been
more black babies have died
um
cancer
more than cancer heart disease
violent crime hiv and aids combined
wow that's crazy combined that's more
people have died via abortion than those
combined since 1973. no i i just can't
get behind it because i have i have that
my brother
like my my mom got pregnant when she was
17. so she was like the she could have
aborted my brother
um
and instead she decided to give him up
for adoption and he had a really good
life and
he is a sales software engineer he just
got married
and she had every reason to get an
abortion if she wanted to she just met
my dad so
i i just feel like my mom understood she
made that decision yeah this is the
consequence
everyone knew she was pregnant it was
really embarrassing she gave every no
one wanted her to give him up for
adoption everyone wanted her to keep her
she chose to give him up for adoption
right right and like she dealt with the
consequences and i just don't like i
just feel like women we lack
accountability for the consequences like
if you choose to be irresponsible
well i i i had i had a saying and i said
this on many podcasts
every woman is head of security for her
own vagina yeah you're a head of
security for your own vagina yeah so
whoever you let in
is up to you and that's and that's the
same thing with girls like
like for they'll complain about men or
trash men or trash like this this this
but you
you let them in yeah
yeah you let them in and it's like
that's why i don't really
i just grew up between boys so i don't i
don't really stand with that kind of
[ __ ] right because i just that makes
sense because you probably growing up
when women grow up with guys
they they see two they see kind of both
sides to men they see like the really
dog
like really piece of [ __ ] man
brother is a hell i'm not right that's
what i'm saying so you see that and then
you can see these girls wild and they'll
be commenting on my tick tocks i'm like
what am i supposed to do right but then
you also see the good man you see that
yeah these guys are cool and you know
they're yeah they're not so yeah i get
it when you go out with men you kind of
see both sides unfortunately the mena
dogs mantra has been the one that's been
kind of yeah thrown out yeah for the
past five decades
um did you find the study at all so what
i was gonna say um
i don't want to go with any of these
links that i have pulled up now just
because like because they show that
you're talking [ __ ] is that what it is
because they're mostly dot-coms like i i
want to go with like actual yeah um yeah
what do you call it like like actual
peer-reviewed articles and stuff like
that i managed to just find one so far
but i would have to actually read this
in detail it's 46 pages long okay i
don't want to have to go through that
but if you yeah just go ahead so it's
like
a national study of
police sexual misc oh god this is very
long it is
i couldn't even find anything that
blatantly sticked down but just stuck
out sorry i just i found when people
like say stats like that and i'm sure
you heard it somewhere like you thought
it would maybe was true um what i know
of it is not that um it's like legal all
over the u.s what it is is that it's not
illegal
in a certain amount of states i just so
what i'm sorry go ahead sorry i don't
know you're good what i know of it as is
that it's like 34 or 35 states that
don't necessarily have a law against it
and there have been cases where
detainees have been assaulted meanwhile
in the rest of the states that do have
laws against it like you know that that
protects the detainee at least
so that just shows you that there's a
problem at all with it well i just
thought that prisoners can't legally
consent to sex
did you guys not hear about the two
prisoners
in the female prison oh no that were
impregnated by the trans person that was
in prison
two prisoners got impregnated by
a woman
in prison because the trans person was
in prison
and did not hear about that yeah it's
crazy happened in i think it was new
jersey as america was it might have been
new jersey or baltimore or something
like
that
but it was probably baltimore yeah i
don't know but
we're not we're not going to rip that
into it
it's crazy it was crazy yeah
well it just like
yeah and then oh my gosh and then you
what if it was just a duties like i want
to get laid
i am a female
if it's consensual
i can't get mad at the end of the day if
the detainee and the officer
really wanted to go at it
by all means i don't think that's nice
but you know but the [ __ ] just
arrested you 15 minutes ago i don't know
why you would do that but
by all means do what you want but when
it's full-blown assault yeah
that's not good okay actually i have a
question for you so um it's going back
to what we're talking about earlier with
the trans people and you're saying like
you empathize more with a lot with them
because of their like
feelings and stuff like
i'm paraphrasing right
but so i have a question i personally
like would not support a law that
allowed trans people in the girls
bathrooms
and i'm gonna tell you why it's not for
the reason you think it's because
when it's not because like some trans
people like like seriously like look
like a girl i wouldn't really care
you're in a stall whatever but the issue
is when you when you talk about a policy
you have to think about people
taking it to the extreme
because at some point someone in the u.s
is going to take that to the extreme
like there are crazy people
and that's where like i think laws are
supposed to protect you right and i
would not want um a girl to get
assaulted
because a man is claiming to be a woman
and going into the girl's bathroom yeah
like if they're not actually a part of
the community
yeah i totally understand that so
because of that like i just think that
that trans people should either have
their own bathrooms or go to what they
were assigned at birth because i i and
it's easy like it's easy to say oh like
think about their feelings and stuff but
what i wouldn't want to see is somebody
get assaulted because in the name of
feelings
okay i understand that yeah but
how
are you going to feel
seeing a trans man for example
full blown on testosterone for god knows
how many years yeah full-blown beard
muscles all that walking into a women's
bathroom you won't be able to tell right
and immediately women are going to react
negatively
let's be honest i think we can say
peacefully that at least a majority of
the trans community
if not all of them
genuinely are not going to do that
they're not going to assault people
people however who are going to use that
terror to their advantage to assault
people now that's a whole different
story but how often does that happen
well yeah but i think it's because we
like bringing up the whole how often
does that happen with me every time i
bring up an issue but how often do we
really think a trans person is going to
be popping up into one of these
bathrooms to purposely assault somebody
well i think the point isn't how often
does it happen i the law is there to
protect you okay that's that's the
purpose of the law
and i think like leah thomas looks like
a dude to me i'm gonna be like i don't
oh yeah he does leah thomas doesn't like
like i i don't think that leah thomas
even slightly resembles a female and if
i saw the atomos in a bathroom even
though he's been on testosterone or like
whatever
estrogen yeah whatever for a year i
would feel so uncomfortable if he
whipped his like dick like i would i
would feel in a locker room and i i
think i should legally be protected from
that like i shouldn't have to see men's
parts in the women's bathrooms
there were two cases that i i spoke on
about a year ago in america one was a
a man who identified as a woman
at a spa
in the
sauna and
female changing room
going into the changing room
and then whipping off his towel
and there was a woman in there who had a
young child i guess her daughter was
like 12
in there too with her and she came out
was that there's a guy in there walking
around with his thing swinging yeah
saying that he's a woman
and they wouldn't do anything about it
because they were like ma'am he
identifies as a woman that's a woman
second one
was there's a waxing company in america
um who does like female brazilian yeah
and one of the person one of the people
got upset about that because the
esthetician said that they were not
trained to do the waxing that they asked
for
is it that one no it's when the guy came
in to get a wax
the guy or the girl
biologically you could just say the
person a bile like it's really not that
hard the biological man went into a
woman's waxing salon and asked for a wax
they said no we don't wax men this is a
female waxalon and he wanted to soothe
them for transphobia
yeah and i had seen that story and the
esthetician said herself that she was
not capable of doing that because she's
not trained for it not even just the
company but like the woman itself i had
looked very deeply into this i fully
agree with that the whole situation i
get that like if these people are not
trained for it
they're not going to do it and if it's
for women only it's for women only just
accept that like
when it comes to this person in
particular
i'm not done talking if you kept
listening then you would have known that
i was going to say something
for this person in particular
who is trans and identifies as a woman
what they should have done was look for
a waxing center that is more inclusive
and not only um experienced in just
working with cis-gender women that don't
have like bottom top surgery whatever it
may be that it's up to them to do that
research at the end of the day so then
do you agree like them back to the
bathrooms like that they can be women
only and biological women only when it
comes to bathrooms again a little bit
teeter-totter with that because um at
least in the east coast like you see a
lot of like gender-neutral bathrooms
so like
i'm just like okay as long as it's
inclusive like you know as long as
whoever is not comfortable going to
either bathroom regardless of their
gender
if they have a third option i think that
is a good thing
um
so if anything i probably would agree
with you to a certain degree
um i think we just have to be
a little realistic because when it comes
to the whole like assigned at birth
thing like going to the bathroom
according to your assigned sex
we can't really do that with like trans
men going into a women's bathroom okay
first of all can i just say something
like
this whole assigned that birth thing
is a nonsensical argument
and this whole cis thing is a
nonsensical argument
a cisgender person is somebody who is
born woman or man and identifies
listen as men and women
we don't have to take on other people's
terminologies for us right so if
somebody's going to attempt to give
a man
a title
as a man
i don't have to take your title
don't tell me a cisgendered man
i'm a man
i don't i don't i don't need to take
your title so when people just throw out
these terms oh a cisgender man is like
you are putting titles on people that
don't even accept your titles like if i
decided to put a title upon you that you
never accepted i don't think that's fair
but the thing is what i've noticed is
with the quote-unquote trans community
they feel as if they can give people
titles right that they don't even accept
themselves
and it's just like i don't think that's
fair because that now says that your
arrogance and your ego has got out of
control where you think you can now
label somebody who doesn't even accept
attack i'm a man i'm not a cisgendered
man
i'm a man
okay it's really that simple if you call
yourself a woman someone says oh
pearl you're a cisgendered woman is that
the title that you give yourself or is
it the title that they put upon you
yeah
no
does that make sense yeah no that makes
sense because you're saying it's like
disrespectful to like of course to just
label somebody yeah because but the
thing is it seems like it's okay when it
comes to the trans community they're
allowed to label other people whereas
they've labeled themselves yeah they've
given themselves a title
all right what do you think
[Laughter]
are you good jessica
[Music]
we can talk about just listen to this
dude go off no biggie
um so
who do you think
came up with the terminology
gender
um i don't know
let me know
lgbt no it came from a german sexologist
in the 90s okay um and this man is he
considered himself
cisgender yeah all right yeah cisgender
male 1 he was he was funding that he was
born a man
and raised as a man and
fully considered himself he him whatever
yeah
so
we can't just sit here and think that
the lgbt community is out here just
labeling other people because we're not
we're going based off of well the reason
terminology that was created by
sexologists
to properly
refer to other people what does cis mean
then
you could i just explained it twice
no what if you're not listening because
i know what a man is go ahead
so cis man born male
goes with being identified as male same
thing with women born as a woman and
goes with being a woman
like this stuff just sounds like
nonsense to me it's like like because it
just sounds like like delusion because
you're saying like you have to do all
these terms to say the same thing you
don't have to no you're right you you
really no ain't nobody forcing none of
these [ __ ] to go with any of
these terminology however i do that to
be more inclusive to people
by choice because i want to be more
respectful and i want to be more
inclusive towards people who feel like
they are not being represented do you do
you feel like we always have to be
inclusive to people
that depends on the situation okay
genuinely because like sometimes i think
like some people should be excluded
because you know what you know what i
know like like what if like what if like
um okay let's take let's take um like
black lives matter
like then when people said oh all lives
matter
that kind of what about that like do you
don't you feel like do you feel like
like in that case they were trying to
exclude
do i feel like black people were trying
to exclude other races yeah no no or
like like not at all
because that is the issue that people
have with black lives matter they think
that we're saying that other people
don't matter we're not we're trying to
emphasize that we matter too yeah as
much as other lives but we are being
oppressed the most out of anybody else
based on our race but that's why i'm
saying like that's why the movement like
like if
like the movement isn't about other
races as much as it is about like black
in a way you're people
other races but we have to because we
have to capitalize on our issues i'm not
taking away from that but i'm saying i
think there's some cases where people
should be excluded and that's one of
them yes yes that is absolutely it right
i genuinely feel that way about plenty
of situations in which a minority is
being oppressed and other people need to
recognize that this is not their battle
so but that's what i'm saying like in
the case of women i think trans people
should be excluded from
us because they're not women and like we
have our own issues and we have things
that we fight for and are specifically
to women right i don't think you get to
pretend to be a woman just like i can't
pretend to be black right
like i don't like i don't think you get
to like take away you get to take away
our awards you get to take away
um our our athletics
you get to take away our all of our
women's only spaces okay they're they're
taking these away from us and just like
if there was like you know black lives
matter if someone said okay let's make
it white lives matter like like that
would be that that people would be in an
uproar they would be yeah you know but
now um i just remembered this whole
thing um when it comes to like the
swimmers right like have you brought up
um leah thomas and
how this person had
i guess they blew away the competition i
assume like oh yeah
in first place
they were like 90 seconds behind or some
crazy stuff like that here's the thing
with yeah here's the thing with battling
um biological
uh situations and
being put in a certain category for
competition right when we look at
someone like michael phelps
he does not produce lactic acid in his
legs okay but he blows away the
competition every single time because he
can't produce it that we know what like
that lactic acid in our calves feels
like i'm gonna be honest i don't know so
lactic acid is what builds up after um
long-term training right so it's like
the burning sensation that you feel in
your calves or like your legs more
likely
um because he can't produce that he's
already at an advantage so naturally he
will have a much longer stamina however
he's been allowed to um compete his
entire swimming career
so does that mean that he should not
have been allowed to compete because he
was at an advantage at that point and
this is just a question i'm asking like
not whether or not i believe that he
doesn't he says he doesn't
not produce it he produces half as much
lactate which is a huge difference
compared to the average person i think
that's okay that's like
i know a girl that's six five
okay okay like and she had a huge
advantage when it came to recruiting
right if you're 65 you have a d1 but
that's an expectation for sports
your height like your height and build
are the two things that coaches and
recruiters look at the most right right
but i'm saying i think there's a
difference between having an advantage
but you're still you're still a
biological manners biological woman okay
like i think there's a difference
between just having an advantage you
know amongst your group okay and having
them come into our group and blowing all
of us out of the water okay
because like imagine imagine jessica you
know how hard we train we train so hard
yeah
bro i've been in this damn sport for
nine years so i understand now imagine
working your whole life and you having
to sit the bench this year because a
dude's in front of you
like like
it's not it's not fair i mean no matter
what i'm not going to um
disrespect that person's identity and
all that i will be upset i will be
honest because it's like i know at the
end of the day if that person's not been
on estrogen for long enough they're not
going to have the same
even close to biological build as me and
me knowing that i have trained so hard
to get to whatever point i need to be
it's going to be done up for me i don't
think there's ever a point because let's
let's even take height okay
i'm i'm tall i'm the top one percent of
height for females
i if amongst men i'm in the top 15
percent of height
the reason that i compete well you see
me compete i'm strong and i'm tall yeah
and i have long arms but amongst men i'm
not that strong i'm not that tall and i
don't have that long of arms
because 15 percent of men are taller
than me i'd be blown out i would have no
opportunity
and it's like how is that fair
i get you like no i don't i don't
disagree like i i fully see both sides
of the situation because no matter what
i want to respect um
trans people wanting to be able to
compete now i'll be honest like back in
high school at least before i did at
least a little bit more research on this
right i believed that they should have
had their own um
like league you know yeah but the reason
why i believe this is because i'm one of
those people where it's like if you
don't like the way something is
do something about it right so something
that upset me constantly
was seeing um
trans women get upset about not being
able to be a model for victoria's secret
right um now personally i could give a
[ __ ] about victoria's secret they're not
even that good no more uh it's all fenty
baby
but
um i felt like you know what if these
people aren't accepting you
do something else make your own company
make your own lingerie company if you
want like
if you want make your own trans modeling
company or agency i mean right because i
genuinely feel like we have more of a
platform to do what we want right at the
end of the day it's not the same as like
the 60s you know where like someone
would shoot us down for it right and
because of that like i i again i don't
really see what i mean i i could see the
argument for abortion right like
and i'm sure feminists like would rather
have more and more abortion rights fine
like i i understand that at least but
outside of that like
i can't see what on earth we're fighting
for like to be honest like what we need
feminism for
because i guess things are quite equal
now yeah there's nothing stop as you
just said there's nothing stopping us
from going and starting whatever company
we want to start i'll tell you what it
is like but that's why i was saying
what we're fighting for more is just
going against assault and rape and
um
like bodily autonomy like i said like i
really think that's our main um thing
because you know what i realized like
even when i speak to other people about
women's rights
none of us are really complaining about
like
you know [ __ ] like not getting paid
enough or like not getting opportunities
or anything like that if anything some
of us are getting a little bit more
opportunities because we're pretty and
like this and that you know i i think i
hear girls say that all the time on my
show they talk about pay gap yeah i've
brought it up dude this is a pay gap i
will i won't go against you they know
why there's a pickup though po that's
the question
um
so
does my voice irritate you
i don't think he's i think he's just
trying to i'm actually asking the
question like
does like do they know the reason for
the pay gap a lot of times no they think
it's like the patriarchy or society
right but it's not it's women's choices
right
but um the most high-paying jobs
right
women aren't necessarily willing to do
them but there are plenty of situations
where women will be in the same um
what's the word um same position i'll
just say like same job position as a lot
of other men within the same company
let's say
that realize that they are getting paid
less than their male counterparts who
even may have been at the company for a
far less amount of time than they have
been right now that that's more of a
company issue that's illegal i can't say
that like that's like a statewide or
country-wide issue why that is chesca
though
because of personality differences
between men and women men are more
disagreeable
so if they get offered a salary they're
more likely to say f that'll go work for
another and then screw you or they're
more likely to try and negotiate a
better deal yeah or negotiate or say i'm
not going to take that
and like in that case i think i'm just
around a lot of ambitious women then
because i feel like i don't know anybody
like that but like i said i can only
speak from my perspective it's kind of
like it's okay in this conversation
right
who who's more pleasant to talk to me or
sarah
you've been said no but it's because of
personality differences right like he's
more disagreeable i'm more agreeable
because i'm a woman
and we naturally like we
i'm disagreeable
but but it's not it's not a bad thing
right because you know sarah can have
some really cool moments for like on the
on the internet you know but
but like but like you see what i'm
saying like it's the same thing in in a
company like like sarah would probably
be more likely to say oh screw that i'll
go work for someone else or i'm not
going to take that job or i'm like good
enough
i would
in that it's true because i would in my
workplace i'd be like hang on a minute
so i'm doing this i'm doing that and i'm
doing that and this is what you're
paying me i know some or i'll go down
below i know a place that wants me for
the same job but they're going to pay me
x
what are you willing to do about that
right well and and and the the thing is
even with my channel i i run all of my a
lot of my decisions through men because
i know they're naturally better at that
yeah they can get you the best deal yeah
like like um we're talking about
bringing on a producer now and i'm
having my manager talk to him because do
you drive what do you drive
i'm saying so there's a reason why when
men go to a mechanic and women go to a
mechanic women get charged more than men
yeah right because remember we're like
what it's not what no but i know no my
other mechanic can no no that's not that
we'll be like how much is it okay yeah
but you see like that's not patriarchy
that's personality differences no i i
totally agree with that like um
me on the other hand
i know how to handle those types of
situations but i think that's because i
was raised by my dad and i have dated
guys who give me insight on these kinds
of things you know like when it comes to
cars for example if i were to have a car
a mechanic is never going to get me like
right just know that these [ __ ]
are never going to get me yeah but um
but that's the thing
we don't prioritize teaching women these
kinds of things at the end of the day
either you know like
we have to think about it like it's very
stereotypical like dad teaches son how
to throw a baseball and how to fix a car
and the daughter's gonna go play with
the doll or whatever like we
naturally in society we are a little bit
more traditional we're not thinking
about
teaching our kids these things until
it's like too late half the time well i
don't think it's a bad thing i don't
think we should have to try to change
how we are because i know i don't i
don't think so i think it's just um
important to keep in mind
that
these things are less like gender-based
and more just like survival skills right
like knowing how to not get
ripped off by your mechanic so that your
car can make it longer kind of situate
like that's just something you should
teach your kid period yeah but like i
don't know i think it's just more
gender-based but you do have to
understand that when a mechanic sees a
woman walk in and when he sees a man
walking he's thinking two different
things
yeah yes it's too he's he and he and if
he has looked your car over
and he's looked the man's car over even
if he's trying to you know get the best
deal out of both of you he's gonna he's
going to approach the situation with a
little bit more tact when it comes to
the man over the woman have you ever
seen
the
tick tock trend where you call your dad
and tell him that you something about
like wiper fluid or something or
blinkers
dad i paid a thousand dollars for a
wiper
i did that my dad killed me
where a woman said to her her guy that
the guy charged her in a mechanic to
actually pump in the tires
it's like the air is like free and she
was like yeah i paid like a hundred
dollars
he went and he said what he went nuts
but that's what i'm saying though is
that like we should make it less
gender-based and more like this is
something we should teach our kids so
that they don't get ripped off
regardless of their gender right um it's
the same thing with like just basic life
skills like cooking we don't expect men
to cook but
there may come a time where that
[ __ ] is going to live alone
men cook all the time in the caribbean
yeah that's nice and all but that we can
tell that that's not the case everywhere
right
i don't think like women i don't know a
lot of women that really like cook like
that i'm i'm i'm i'm the black one
damn shame dude
because no matter what regardless of
gender you need to know how to sustain
yourself
you have to know how to cook clean
whatever it may be like regardless of
your gender if you don't know the sheer
basics of survival i live by myself
since i was like 21 years old yeah so i
had to know how to cook and how to do
all these things and you know i just
i had to learn so the other the other
thing you said was like bodily autonomy
is like sexual assault and like grape
that sort of thing
but i'm just cute like what laws
because the way i look at it is again
due to personality differences like men
are more disagreeable and that's why men
in general like commit more crimes
because of that person out like men are
naturally more aggressive right i agree
but um
but that's that's something you can't
really change
but like in general in most states grape
you go to jail for
sexual assault you you can you go in the
west do you mean i i would actually
advocate for longer prison sentences for
people that do actually i would advocate
for the death penalty
but see like that's my point though you
get life sentences for that for granted
no no they can't never that would never
happen
predators like get out i that's what i'm
saying the fact that they can get out or
like not even like so i i'm i'm the type
of person where
if somebody is going to get jailed i
would also want them to get rehab of
some sort right because as long as
they're sitting in a jail cell and not
getting any kind of like rehabilitation
or education on how to fix themselves
and not be an [ __ ] like
don't get me wrong that everybody can be
fixed in that sense but at least
understand what they did wrong yeah like
these problems are always gonna happen
they're not gonna come out of jail fully
reformed right like let's be honest i
think they don't come out of jail like i
literally think if you if you
grape someone and i'm not talking about
i'm talking about like you you pull a
girl off the street great drive down the
alley yeah yeah that's sort of great
if you do that or if you
touch a child death penalty in pearl's
world probably if you promise
to say this talking about this i was
watching a video the other day
do you know what a map is
a map what's a map um
i remember seeing that all over twitter
for the longest but it's a minor
attracted person yeah
so there's a new terminology now for
mine people that are attracted to minors
and they're calling a map
minor attracted person and then the way
that they refer to
boys and girls is like a hot dog or a
pizza
that's disgusting it is well and that's
that's honestly though why i'm against
sex ed in schools
i think i think if if they
i i i think
you got to look at it from a predator's
point of view that's that's giving like
predators access to children 100 like
and and like but how so
because you're you're you're basically
teaching kids how to have sex jessica
but that doesn't mean that the children
are consenting to these full-blown
adults that are engaging with them okay
and putting them in these compromising
situations okay so say say you're this
is a weird like way to look at it but
pretend you're a predator for a second
you're trying to you're trying to get a
kid okay because that's kind of how you
have to look at it from like a parent
like i'm sure as a parent like like you
know you want to protect your kid 100 so
so if you were a predator what are ways
you could get access to kids right one
you can go and work in where the kids
are yeah you work where the kids are and
so and i've had a situation where i had
a coach that like um he would wait till
girls turned 18
and try to hook up with us so i had like
a coach that i trained like a lot with
one-on-one for like years and i look
back and i thought he was testing the
waters like throughout the years where
he would like say things that were kind
of like
like i don't know just out of pocket
like right and and really weird in
hindsight to say to like a 15 16 year
old girl do you know do you think he was
like grooming yeah oh he totally oh my
god he totally was but like i'm just
someone i always like assume the best
i'll just be like oh he didn't mean it
like that or like whatever but when you
know he said
what did he say to me he he would like
ask me about
like stuff with like
like who i was dating and like that like
to test the water see how i reacted and
then to keep push like pushing it
pushing and pushing it until they
and he would do this to other girls too
until we would turn 18 and then try to
hook up with us right
and um
and i just see like sex ed is like
giving predators the opportunity to do
that but the thing is they're going to
do that regardless of the course being
given right now let's not make it
that's what makes it easier
the whole point of teaching children sex
ed is for awareness not teaching them
how to have sex it's just awareness
right understanding bodily autonomy
these are the parts that should not be
touched especially like whether it be
from another child or an adult it should
not happen whatsoever and it would be a
way as teaching them like defend
yourself like not necessarily like fight
to the dead the thing is though none of
you have children and i'm not like
that's not in a disrespectful way but
when you actually have children
your
your um
your mindset changes
when you actually have one in your
vicinity all the time
your mindset changes as to how because
because there's
there's talking about innocence
and they're seeing it on a day-to-day
basis
and when i see my son's in it i grew up
with my son when i see my son's
innocence and i see what he's like
the
the feelings that i have towards
anyone who was even going to attempt to
take his innocence away
i know i would level the planet i would
level this whole planet do you know what
i mean and so
a lot of the time
people talk about these things with
children oh but sexy you don't know what
it's like to take away a child's
innocence so you don't know what it
looks like to see innocence on a date
because once you take it away they can't
get it back right you can't get it back
get it back and like i don't understand
like why does the school know when the
best time is to tell a kid about that
stuff like as as a parent you know your
kid better than anyone 100 people you
know if if he's like
every kid is different and needs to be
parented differently and as a parent
like you're going to know what what kid
is wild and you're going to want to tell
that to sooner and what one can be
innocent until they're 16 17. like like
i have i have you know four sisters and
i could tell you like one sister maybe
needed to have that talk as soon as
possible another sister she could have
waited until she was 18. it would never
have been an issue because she was
innocent up until that time
yeah because it's just like there's
personality
differences you were going to know more
than a a school ever is going to or
i fully agree but that's why i brought
up earlier that there's going to be a
difference between the school explaining
it from a scientific perspective right
versus our parents
you know sitting down and actually
having to talk with us and saying like
how it should be carried out you know
like whether or not like
you shouldn't be super sexually active
or you have to use condoms and so on and
so forth right like do you do you think
evidence matters
so do you think like if if
i would say there's very little evidence
that sex ed actually helps kids
reduce in pregnancies outside of wedlock
um so do you do you think if there's
very little evidence that it helps
that maybe it's not effective
i think it's something that would
probably just have to be researched
further before we could even come to
that conclusion sorry sorry
um i'm more so somebody who
wants more quantitative and qualitative
research at the same time when it comes
to this kind of stuff i fully believe in
like long-term research and this kind of
stuff because we can't make that
decision until like
there's even like if we started this
search now right like let's say we took
a bunch of fifth graders and um
you know looked at each school
curriculum curriculum in each state and
studied them for 10 years that's still
not going to give us enough evidence
well you realize it's been implemented
around the 70s that's what yeah so we
have that's a lot of data to go off of
but the problem is that every state is
so different even school curriculums in
the same state are so different right
right like they prioritize different
ways of teaching it like
i would say that my sex ed program was
great for um our age group because again
they looked at it from such a scientific
perspective when we first started out
right right they're just like this is
what boys have this is what girls have
girls can have a period and this is how
you take care so what evidence would you
need to like disprove something
disprove so like like so your opinion is
like like and this could be with
anything but sometimes i feel like
regardless of the evidence like people
believe what they're going to believe
right so so my question is like what
evidence do you really need to see to
change an opinion on something if
anything
like how many studies would it take if i
if i after this interview sat down and
taught you a study ten studies i
probably will i'm gonna be honest i
don't i don't get a lot of free time i
probably won't but if i if i sat down
and sent you ten studies from ten
different states that all
indicate that sex ed in schools equals
more sex more unplanned pregnancies more
this more that would that change your
mind or would you i would have to look
at um
where those things are coming from
that's my like like i said that's why i
look at both quantitative and
qualitative because right quality really
is a lot but quantity matters in the
sense that are they all
quality so then for you pearl what would
sex education look like where would it
come from parents like i just think the
the government has no business in doing
that do you understand this also some
parents are absolutely [ __ ] given um
some parents are not there
i mean i i agree with you it's not a
perfect it's never going to be a perfect
system but i just think how can a
stranger there's nobody that is
more incentive to make that kid turn out
to be a good person than the parents
there's so then what okay but there are
[ __ ]
let's think about it in this sense like
how society looks down on people who are
more sexually positive like such as like
people with only fans and all that
would you feel
what would you feel would you feel more
comfortable knowing that there would be
a lot of only fans models out there
teaching their kids
like you know what i don't believe they
should be only fans in the first place
okay that doesn't answer the question
am i comfortable with them teaching that
yeah i mean no i wish they wouldn't
but like i just
again i think that there's nobody with a
vested more of a vested interest in the
kid turning out okay and i would guess
that at some point and i would guess at
some point like i don't know i've talked
to a decent amount of like not not only
fans models but strippers that say i
would never encourage my kid to do this
yeah
and so does that mean they know that
it's wrong
they have no it's something that they're
too young to understand at that point
because that is where there's a little
more emotion involved when it comes to
like stripping or um looking at sexual
content online as opposed to just
talking about again the scientific
foundation of what sex is right like
like i said like when it comes to
teaching children this they're just
saying like this is what grown-ups do
yeah and this is how you can have a
child yeah right and this is how you
practice safe sex meanwhile when you're
consuming sexual content online that's a
whole different ballpark that you're
working on i just wouldn't want my oh my
gosh i wouldn't want my kid don't teach
my kid how to have sex don't do that i
don't think they're teaching the kid how
to have sex i think they're telling them
they're telling them about sex they're
telling them about saying they're
probably not saying this
let's talk about it this way okay let me
let me teach them how to do drugs safely
yeah let's let's give them the tools if
they ever do drugs do it safe like if i
had it okay so like the dare program you
would be against that bro yeah i get
that
what's the dare program
the dare program is like i did nothing
something something whatever there is
like all over the country and they tell
us about what drugs are gateway drugs
and what the hardcore drugs are and why
we shouldn't touch them and what the
sentences are if we were ever caught
with them and that kind of stuff right
okay
i mean i i'd like to talk to my own son
about drugs like i just i'm a [ __ ] and
i'd like to talk to him about sex
that's why it should be it should be the
family like why is the government but
not everybody has a family that cares
that is probably the problem
i think that's the reason why that ever
became a concept people have got adults
out there that give birth to them and
don't give birth to them not everybody's
meant to be a parent let's just be
honest i agree i agree but i just think
again it's going back to the incentives
yeah like there's nobody that is more
incentive than a kid turning out okay
like but there's far more people in this
world that are truly not meant to be
parents than we think
right like
there's a reason why there's so many
this is the reason why the world looks
like it's burning right now because so
many people have such different morality
and different perspectives now there's
nothing wrong with that because the
world would be a boring place if we were
all on the same page right like i feel
like
i think we have to have our different
senses
deserve a two-parent i i i think they're
nice but unfortunately not everybody's
gonna get that there needs to be some
core things that we all agree on yeah i
don't think everyone should be the same
and think the same yeah but i do need to
be some like core things that we agree
on yeah i i get what you're saying
jessica that the whole world would be
boring it's not all the same i get that
but i do think there are some core
things that all humans regardless of
race religion politics that's the
problem is that actually we both have
different core beliefs on certain things
right like abortion for example that
already
opens up a whole can of worms
so
you think it's okay then
to kill babies in the wind
my point is that
abortion is matter
i agree i agree i think it's murder like
it doesn't
what my original point was that yeah
everybody is going to think that their
opinion matters the most and that they
have the most moral value compared to
the other person but none of us can
determine that absolutely none of us
because tomorrow
die on our hill
no matter what but it doesn't [ __ ]
matter at the end of the day
so then does it come does it come back
to you know what you do your thing i'll
do mine as long as you don't encroach
upon my human rights and i don't
encroach upon yours i fully believe that
but that's how i've always felt from the
start i feel like as long as what you're
doing is not harming yourself right
other people or animals
gucci go do whatever the hell you want
that's how we're we're still friends
right we agree on nothing
we agree on nothing
but that is genuinely my point as long
as you're not harming yourself or other
people and animals
you're good to go dog yeah like don't
just don't put anybody in a compromising
situation
yeah no i agree
um
i think i'm gonna end the live on that
though that's okay
all of us agreeing on one
do you guys have thing closing thoughts
um
yeah then this my closing thought on
feminism in general
is that um it's become a pointless
exercise nowadays i think feminism has
become a pointless exercise
and
i i understand its origin and why it was
initially initially sorry um
i guess enacted
but
now i think it's just a bunch of
women complaining about things that
actually don't need to be complained
about okay
my closing thoughts are
[Music]
say something nice to yourself
and say something nice to someone else
say something nice to me and
maybe the world will be a better place
say something nice to me um remember to
keep an open mind i guess even when it's
hard to okay i'm giving my closing
thoughts i don't know why you want to
steal the spot like so bad are you
desperate oh my god
okay thank you okay guys
like i said uh sending lots of love to
y'all even if y'all hate me
yeah guys actually i was gonna say
something i forgot to say to the
beginning stop insulting my guests i
want them to come back be nice right
chat
um
other thing um make sure you guys go
follow them on
youtube for sarah and you have a youtube
just tick tock you should make a youtube
yes i used to
go follow me on my youtube um sarah
garvey have you have you linked have you
put the uh
i will you will all right good good
that's my fault i could probably put it
in there yeah why don't you do it now
i'll put it in there right now yeah
i was rushing when we started it's okay
i'll edit it into the description
yeah i'll i'll just put it in the live
link um
yeah you guys go follow me if you like
what i'm saying even if you don't like
what i'm saying um
i got content daily for y'all
and so yeah thank you
yeah thanks for coming guys no problem
again i think it's really important to
have conversations with people that you
disagree with so i really appreciate you
coming on i know that my comments
section can be rough so i really really
appreciate you coming on i try my best
dog and appreciate you coming too that's
okay
um okay guys don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell
um thank you for the super chats i'm
sorry i don't in these conversations i
really try to stay engaged so i wasn't
really reading super chats today so very
very sorry but i swear to god
tune in to